18 heures mitri mouratov c'est lui
l'homme derrière novaïa gazeta le
journal indépendant le plus influent de
toute la russie est désormais lé très
fiers lauréat du prix nobel de la paix
il a dû se frayer un chemin parmi les
caméras
encore sous le choc il n'y croit
inutile ce prix c'est la reconnaissance
du sacrifice ultime de mes collègues
journalistes dit il les six de notre
journal qui sont morts ou non de la
liberté de presse ce dont la photo
tapissent les fenêtres de l'édifice et
qu'il a nommé à 1 et 2 rebonds you're a
shit à tout
comme anna politkovskaïa assassinée il
ya 15 ans exactement pour ses enquêtes
sur les abus du régime à szczecin un
emblème du prix à payer en russe
ce nobel n'est pas le mien dit il je
leur dédie à eux ils disparu
fondée en 1993 avec une partie défend
que michail gorbatchev avait reçu à
l'époque de son propre nobel le journal
novaïa gazeta a fait sa marque à travers
le monde grâce à des reportages
courageux spectaculaire et critique du
kremlin une mission que mouratov n'a
jamais abandonné même dans un climat de
répression qui est à son comble ici en
lui décernant le prix nobel à lui et à
sa consoeur journaliste maria laisse à
des philippines le comité a aussi voulu
rendre hommage à toute une profession
qui est menacée et new world in which
the
increasing
une immense victoire pour ce qui reste
de la presse indépendante en russie des
organisations constamment pourchassés et
considéré agents étrangers et avec qui
le journaliste mouratov al'intention de
partager sa blouse
mouratov n'était pas le seul russe en
nomination ils étaient d'ailleurs
convaincus que l'opposant et avocat
alexeï navalni et serait choisi pour son
courage et sa lutte contre la corruption
moyens tu perds ton temps tu reconnais
son tour viendra dit et j'en suis
convaincu ce nobel de la paix n'en n'est
pas moins un pied n'est au kremlin qui
étouffe toute voix dissidente y compris
est de plus en plus celle de la presse
indépendante
itamar alter escaut radio-canada moscou